you
hi I'm Dushyant narnun I'm a researcher
at Microsoft Research in Cambridge in
the UK and I'm gonna tell you about farm
and a-one which me and my team have been
working on over the last five years if
we look at distributed computing
platforms today we have good platforms
for batch computation at scale such as
cosmos or MapReduce which can run large
computations over thousands of machines
for minutes to hours and we also have
good platforms that can provide a low
latency but they don't scale out and
farm is a platform for providing low
latency at scale the farm makes it easy
to build low latency scale out
applications by hiding the things that
make distributed applications hard which
is concurrency failures and data
distribution so farm abstracts this away
and provides the programmer with the
abstraction of a single machine that
cools the resources of the entire
cluster runs transactions one at a time
and doesn't fail and the way we do this
is by providing distributed transactions
with strict serialize ability which is
varies from consistency and high
availability disability transactions are
a very old idea but in the past
people thought they wouldn't scale and
that they wouldn't perform well and in
farm we showed that within the data
center we can have distributed
transactions with very strong
consistency high availability and great
performance right and to achieve this we
leverage the hardware that's present in
our Azure data centers today so
plentiful and cheap DRAM means we can
keep the working set of applications in
memory for low latency lithium ion
batteries integrated in the racks let us
make this memory non-volatile at low
cost and fast our DMA networking lets us
cut the cost of scale out
now the hardware alone doesn't give us
this performance so there was a huge
amount of work to get the performance
out of the hardware which involved
redesigning the communication stack and
new distributed systems protocols such
as a novel transaction commit protocol
and a result of this work we have
amazing scalability high throughput and
low latency and extremely high
availability so for an example we can
recover two full throughput from a
failure in 67 milliseconds in this
experiment which is less time then some
systems take to commit a single
transaction even when they don't have
failures so farm as a research idea
started about five years ago right and
we did foundation research and farm over
the next two years and over the last
three years we have been pushing farm to
production as well as building a one a
graph database that we're exposing to
internal customers and Microsoft because
there was a huge need for a good graph
platform with high performance
scalability and high availability and so
where we are now is that we've just gone
live with our first scenario for this
graph platform my colleague alex is
going to talk about that
hi my name is Alec Sheamus and I work
with Duchenne and a bunch of other
people to build to build farm and then
our partner products called a1 a1 is a
distributed graph database that we've
built to help accelerate applications
that need to use graphs and you have to
have consistent graphs but a too big to
fit one application and I'll show an
example of what we've been managed what
we've been able to do and what would be
now to put into a production using the
technology that Duchenne she talked
about in farm along with all the other
people that worked on farm and aid the
a1 products so using a being query there
was recently a news article saying that
Russell Wilson is the most sacked
football player in the NFL so an
interesting question be so who has been
who sacks Russell Wilson so much and let
who are the statistics on this so we can
type into being who sacra's Wilson the
most and then in seconds we get a
results we get this results showing that
the people that have sacrificed the most
is Robert Quinn this query you once it
comes to our back end
execuse a six hop graph query that does
22,000 reads and we're able to perform
this in tens of milliseconds so this is
just a small example of what would be
able to do with farm and a1 and put into
production with being thank you
you